bonjour merci d'être avec nous en ce
dimanche midi jusqu'à 13h est-ce que
vous êtes ministre de l'agriculture ou
des agriculteurs je suis ministre de
l'Agriculture et par nature quand vous
êtes ministre de l'Agriculture vous vous
souciez de ce pour qui vous travaillez
avec qui il faut faire les transitions
c'est à dire pour les agriculteurs mais
j'ai aussi ministre de l'alimentaire et
de l'alimentation donc je me préoccupe
aussi de ce que sont les exigences de
nos concitoyens en termes alimentaires
donc c'est plusieurs éléments mais
est-ce que ça veut dire parfois qu'on
peut prendre des décisions qui sont
contraires aux intérêts des agriculteurs
quand on est ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire je
pose pas tout à fait comme ça je pense
que l'intérêt des agriculteurs y compris
parfois quand ils sont mal compris par
eux-mêmes par les agriculteurs c'est de
les engager dans la voie des transitions
parce que c'est leur intérêt aussi à eux
de s'engager c'est pas forcément une
opposition entre les agriculteurs et les
consommateurs ou d'autres qui permettra
d'avancer ça vient d'être dit d'ailleurs
il me semble que ça pourrait être
contre-productif il faut les encourager
et les amener sur le changement de la
transition ce qu'ils font déjà
d'ailleurs mais ils justement à changer
de modèle agricole vraiment nettement
ils sont prêts mais en même temps en
reconnaissant que depuis 60 ans on a
construit un modèle agricole qui a
fonctionné qu'est-ce qu'on a demandé
à la sortie de la guerre on leur a
demandé de produire en quantité de
produire à bas prix et ça a réussi
l'Europe n'était pas autosuffisante pour
sortir de la guerre et donc ils ont fait
ce qu'on leur avait dit de faire et ils
l'ont fait avec grand talent et grande
force désormais nous sommes dans un
nouveau contexte qui est un contexte lié
à de nouvelles exigences et nécessitant
environnementales et puis au contexte
dont on va parler et puis Charmed check
en est l'occasion aussi du dérèglement
climatique qui bouleverse ce système
alors quand vous êtes dans un système
qui est à ce point bouleversité et qui
produit du stress y compris pour les
agriculteurs évidemment c'est plus
difficile de faire ce mouvement et de se
projeter à moyen long terme quand la
question c'est parfois simplement le
court terme et donc ils sont prêts parce
qu'il voit bien les dérèglements
climatique je crois très peu
d'agriculteurs qui ne voient pas les
dérèglements climatiques et qui ne
voient pas les nécessités de changer
sauf que dans ce qui ces périodes de
grand bouleversement c'est toujours un
peu compliqué reconnaissant le et est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment aujourd'hui
que le dérèglement climatique est
compatible avec ce modèle agricole qui
domine aujourd'hui modèle d'agriculture
intensive et est-ce que vous vous êtes
là justement pour essayer de trouver un
nouveau modèle on sait que ça existe
dans l'industrie ça existe dans d'autres
domaines on parle des voitures
électriques etc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour l'agriculture vers où est-ce qu'on
va alors il y a deux sujets sur le
dérèglement climatique si vous me
permettez de répondre à deux parties la
première c'est l'adaptation des
règlements climatiques parce que les
dérèglements climatique il est pas
devant nous on est dedans et les
intestival que nous avons vécu il
produit à la fois des aléas climatiques
vous en avez parlé de la sécheresse de
la grêle du gel tardif et aussi des
inondations mais le fait qu'on soit
dedans fait qu'il va falloir aller
encore plus vite et donc non mais ça
produit sur la production et sur la
nécessité qu'on les agriculteurs de
s'adapter s'adapter par les pratiques
s'adapter sur les questions d'eau
s'adapter sur des tas de choses la
formation l'innovation pour faire en
sorte que le monde agricole puisse mieux
se préparer à se dérèglement quand on
sait de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse
aujourd'hui qui pas exister pendant un
grand nombre d'années puis un deuxième
élément c'est de lutter contre les
règlements climatiques c'est-à-dire
quelle est la part que peut prendre
l'agriculture à la décarbonation c'est
donc c'est sur ces deux sujets qu'il
faut bouger à la fois c'est un sujet à
la fois ils sont quand vous produisez
des automobiles le dérèglement
climatique n'est pas votre sujet c'est
de lutter contre le dérèglement les
agriculteurs ils sont pénalisés à double
titre 1 parce que ça il travaille à ciel
ouvert les usines ne sont pas assez
ouvertes eux leur usine c'est les champs
c'est la météo et donc ils en sont
victimes et en même temps ils doivent
évoluer eux aussi pour apporter leur
contribution à la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et c'est tout le
sujet de la décarbonation de
l'agriculture dans le cadre des bassines
dont on a parlé il y a à la fois des
réserves d'eau si j'ai bien compris
qu'ils sont constitués de manière à ce
que les agriculteurs publient les
utiliser donc ne pas subir ce que vous
disiez le dérèglement climatique et
notamment la sécheresse et d'un autre
côté on les accuse de pomper dans les
nappes phréatiques c'est-à-dire de
participer aux dérèglements de quel côté
êtes-vous et ce que votre considérez que
finalement les écologistes n'ont pas
raison est-ce que je peux reposer le
débat dans la fois en côté micro puis
sur le sujet de sainte solide il tombe
qui a été le sujet qu'on a beaucoup
évoqué cette semaine il tombe 500
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau par an
en France
c'est c'est beaucoup là-dessus il y en a
200 milliards on estime ça c'est
beaucoup mais attendez il y a pas de
temps
attendez 500 milliards
donc ça fait des volumes non non c'est
pas moi qui le dit
donc
ça c'est des chiffres qui sont
l'agriculture prélève 3,5 milliards
là-dessus dans les nappes phréatiques
c'est la moitié de ça le reste c'est de
l'eau de surface donc remettons les
échelles je rappelle que l'eau potable
c'est 5 milliards de mètres cubes je
crois qu'ils sont prélevés chaque année
pour les centrales hydroélectriques
c'est
plus de 10 milliards de mètres cubes qui
sont prélevés chaque année alors c'est
restitué mais en même temps c'est des
prélèvements donc remettons ça dans
l'ordre nous sommes un pays où il y a
ces 3,5 milliards en Espagne c'est 25
milliards en Italie c'est 15 milliards
de mètres cubes qui sont prélevés par
l'agriculture donc j'essaie de remettre
les étages deuxième élément et vous avez
raison on n'a pas le même climat non
plus non non mais on n'a pas les mêmes
climats mais on a une pluviométrie plus
favorable donc le l'appel sur le sur le
sur l'eau qui tombe et moins fort en
France qu'ailleurs deuxième élément il y
a il y a deux pistes sur lequel il faut
qu'on travaille ce que dit le GIEC là
aussi c'est globalement la quantité
d'eau qui va tomber en France y compris
en modèle de dérèglement climatique va
rester la même
la difficulté face à laquelle on est
c'est qu'elle est la pluie qui tombe
elle est beaucoup plus arythmique c'est
à dire qu'on aura des périodes avec
beaucoup d'eau j'étais l'autre jour dans
la Marne au mois de septembre il est
tombé 300 mm il était pas tombé une
goutte d'eau pendant 4 mois c'est la
régulation donc on a un sujet d'arithmie
plus géométrique qui donne du stress sur
les plantes et qui pose des problèmes
alors qu'est-ce qu'on doit avoir comme
piste et c'est ce qui s'est fait sur
Sainte Soline c'est un de faire partout
de voisins de donner la capacité aux
agriculteurs de réduire leur rappel
d'eau leur nécessité d'eau c'est quoi
c'est l'évolution des pratiques c'est
des systèmes qui soient plus économo
c'est des plantes qui soit moins à
appeler de l'eau dans les périodes où il
y en a le plus besoin c'est-à-dire en
période estivale et puis cette constitué
des réserves dans la période estivale je
donne juste sainte solide faut donner
des chiffres au milieu des années 2000
c'était 20 millions de mètres cubes qui
étaient prélevés le projet qu'on a sous
les 20 millions de mètres cubes prélevés
uniquement en période estivale
c'est-à-dire prélevé dans la nappe ou
prélever dans les cours d'eau
le projet qu'on a sous les yeux qui est
un projet qui pour moi est un projet
vertueux c'est plus que 12 millions de
mètres cubes ils sont prélevés 12 à 14
millions et deuxième élément au lieu de
le prélever uniquement en période
estivale c'est-à-dire en période où les
cours d'eau sont plus bas etc on prélève
dans la période où il y en a plus dans
les nappes c'est-à-dire dans la période
hivernale la moitié de ces 12 millions
qui seront prélevés ils seront liés à
ces réserves de substitution c'est pour
ça que ça s'appelle des réserves de
substitution c'est à dire que plutôt que
de prélever dans la période on a le plus
de tension on fait en sorte de prélever
dans la période où il y en a assez et
tout ça est contrôlé alors comme par
ailleurs comme le disait Nathalie tout à
l'heure ce que vous êtes en train de
nous dire c'est que les vers qui
critiquent et les écologistes qui
critiquent ces bassines ont tort alors
j'essaye de pas mettre dans la question
de cattor il a raison j'essaie de donner
est-ce qu'il y a des engagements
demandés tout à l'heure vous parlez en
disant que la des agriculteurs devaient
s'engager à par exemple faire moins de
maïs parce qu'on sait que le maïs ça
consomme beaucoup d'eau est-ce que en
échange de la constitution de ces
bassins vous a demandé des efforts et
sous quelle forme ces sont-ils demandé
ce que c'est écrit ce qui est un pack
dans le dans le proto-velay
en 2018 il y a des engagements sur les
volumes puisqu'on passe on passe de 20
millions à 12 millions un engagement sur
le contrôle des volumes un engagement
sur la réduction des pesticides un
engagement aussi sur le développement de
tout un système je pense au système de
verre on en reparlera peut-être de
système de préservation d'un certain
nombre de surfaces qui ne seraient qui
ne serait pas en blavé si je peux dire
qu'il serait pas utilisé en permanence
pour faire en sorte qu'on fasse plus de
rétention d'eau et qu'on préserve mieux
les équilibres de biodiversité
le préfet peut-être je ne sais pas qui
va vérifier que l'agriculteur
c'est un comité qui seraient compris
composé de gens du BRGM qui est le
l'Institut le bureau qui vérifie le
niveau des nappes et qui autorisera ou
pas d'ailleurs à pomper en hiver selon
le la hauteur des nappes et là ça solide
les agriculteurs étaient nickels les
agriculteurs sont tout à fait
engagés dans cette démarche et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il le vivent un
peu comme un sentiment de découragement
parce que vraiment il y a des efforts
qui sont faits sur sur cette affaire là
on vous parlait du maïs c'est un
territoire de maïsme en 20 ans on a
réduit de deux tiers les surfaces en
maïs dans ce territoire donc ne disons
pas de grâce on essaie d'avancer c'est
compliqué je dis pas que c'est simple
parfois il y a pas des évolutions qu'il
faudrait accélérer mais les écolos en
tout cas les pas que les écolos
d'ailleurs les gens qui sont au style à
ce projet des hydrologues en particulier
évoque la question aussi de
l'évaporation c'est à dire que de mettre
l'air libre comme ça des quantités d'eau
qui théoriquement sont dans les nattes
bah c'est 20 30 40 % peut-être de
d'évaporation c'est pas du tout ce que
donne les données alors
chaque génération engendre ses
hydroziologues qui ont leur propre
pensée mais moi j'essaie de me fier à la
science aussi de ce que dit on piquement
la science on dit plutôt de 3 à 7%
pourquoi parce qu'une partie de ces
réserves d'eau elles vont être aussi
alimenter quand il pleuvra y compris en
période printanière ou estivale elles
vont être alimentées par l'eau qui tombe
du ciel première élément et donc ne
disons pas épique par ailleurs les vapo
transpiration un phénomène naturel un
chêne par jour ça évapore 1000 litres 1
mètre cube chaque chaîne c'est un mètre
cube d'eau qui est vapo transpirer on va
pas supprimer les on va pas supprimer le
boisement parce que ça a d'autres vertus
au motif que ça évapotranscrire les
plantes la nature même de ce qui se
passe dans le cycle de l'eau c'est que
c'est liquide sous forme gazeuse à vous
écouter c'est du bon sens que de faire
sébacine comment est-ce que vous
expliquez l'opposition qu'elle suscite
alors c'est du bon sens sous la réserve
que vous avez évoqué sous la réserve que
par ailleurs on accompagne les
agriculteurs dans l'évolution parfois
des assolements il y a des territoires
qui vont être plus en stress hydriques
que d'autres et donc peut-être il y a
des assolements qu'il faudra faire
différemment c'est du bon sens sous
réserve que il y ait des efforts de fait
pour qu'on a juste le prélèvement de la
nappe au moment où on doit le faire et
qu'on les accompagne en termes
d'investissement la manière dont vous en
parlez on comprend qu'on va en avoir
d'autres que globalement
ce système un outil que vous aimez mais
il y a une nouveau projet mais répondez
quand même à la question pourquoi ça
suscite autant de réactions parce que
dans dans ces domaines là comme dans
d'autres d'ailleurs y compris beaucoup
de domaines
de changer la charge on est trop souvent
dans la caricature et dans l'opposition
on n'essaye pas de poser les sujets
d'avancer tranquillement et est-ce que
c'est bien
la caricature de d'accuser les opposants
au bassines des côtes est-ce que vous
m'avez trouvé caricatural dans mon
propos moi j'essaie d'expliquer des
faits scientifiques c'est des sujets de
nature différente mais
je trouve que sur ce sujet là il y a une
philosophie qui se développe un peu
c'est sur le retour absolu à l'état de
nature faut tout faut tout laisser faire
sauf que dans un stress hydrique un
degré c'est 500 km de l'attitude en plus
ça veut dire que vous aurez le climat de
Toulouse à Rennes
dans le dans les vins ou 30 ans qui
viennent c'est ce que DJ A15 c'est bon
quand le climat change comme ça vous
allez avoir des territoires qui vont
être plus en stress hydrique
reconnaissons c'est pas pour dire du mal
de la météorologie en Bretagne mais
reconnaissant qu'en Bretagne il
connaissait moins le stress hydrique
dans d'autres régions que par exemple en
région Provence à le Côte d'Azur donc ça
doit nous appeler à réfléchir dès lors
que la quantité d'eau qui tombe
est la même à réfléchir à des systèmes
qui soient économe en nous d'une part et
en même temps qui nous permettent
d'avoir de l'eau parce qu'on dit maïs
mais moi j'ai beaucoup de cas et
beaucoup de témoignages cette année sur
les prairies
sur le maraîchage de gens qui ont perdu
80 à 90 % de leur récolte parce qu'ils
avaient besoin d'eau donc on a besoin de
trouver des outils de gouvernance on est
un pays qui aime bien un peu caricaturer
et donc c'est tout petit je repose ma
question vous en voulez plus
c'est-à-dire il va y en avoir de plus en
plus
produit un dérèglement pluviométrique
donc il va falloir prendre la charge
parce que là on parle de sécheresse mais
quand il va tomber 200 ou 300 mm on va
avoir des sujets d'inondation et donc
d'avoir des ouvrages qui permettent en
période de haute eau de récupérer cette
eau pour à la fois pouvoir l'utiliser
l'été mais aussi en période hivernale
pour éviter des débordements qui seront
trop nombreux c'est une logique
implacable c'est une question
d'adaptation c'est là c'est la première
partie de mon propos c'est la question
de l'adaptation des règlements
climatique il est sous nos yeux il
existe il va tomber autant d'eau
essayons de de la raisonner et de
raisonner les choses de manière à faire
en sorte que on puisse gérer les
périodes quand même vous parler en
disant on est dans un pays où on aime
caricaturer vous venez de le dire est-ce
que quand Gérald la Marnaz dit
c'est pas de la caricature non mais il
faisait il faisait référence il faisait
référence pas à l'ensemble des gens je
discute avec les associations
environnementales je trouve que c'est
normal et ça dans un dans un pays
démocratique il faut discuter avec tout
le monde parce qu'on a besoin moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les solutions c'est
pas les problèmes c'est d'essayer de
trouver des solutions mais les actes
qu'on a vu la semaine dernière avec des
gens qui lancent des fusées ils allaient
pas au feu d'artifice
dans la figure de quelqu'un vous risquez
vous risquez de le tuer donc ça c'est
des uns qui sont inacceptables et la
pression moi j'ai eu des agriculteurs et
terrorisme c'est pas la même chose vous
utilisez ce mot là ou pas moi je je veux
mais moi ce mot-là ne me gêne pas dès
lors qu'on voit bien qu'il y a un
certain nombre de
d'actes qui sont des actes de menaces
non pas seulement sur des biens mais
aussi sur des personnes je le disais
j'ai eu des agriculteurs qui sont dans
ce territoire et qui craignaient pour
leur sécurité personnelle parce que
quand vous avez des gens qui sont armés
de barre de fer de cailloux de fusées
comme ça ils sont prennent aux policiers
gendarmes auxquels il faut rendre
hommage parce qu'ils ont essayé eux de
faire un usage proportionné la force et
eux il y avait un usage en face c'est
une minorité mais elle existe quand même
une un usage disproportionné qui menace
non seulement les biens qui menacent les
forces de l'ordre mais qui menacent
aussi les personnes vous avez un
problème qui est un problème très grave
par ailleurs c'est un projet ce projet
là pour les raisons j'évoque de fond
mais aussi de forme c'est un projet qui
a passé tous les écueils juridiques et
tous les écueils qui font qu'on peut
avoir des recours des études des
contrées c'est un projet qui est sur la
table depuis 5-7 ans donc on peut pas
dire qu'il était fait dans la
précipitation il y a même eu des volumes
qui ont été réduits à la demande y
compris du tribunal administratif je
crois que c'était un Poitiers donc il y
a eu des volumes qui ont quant à lui
donc quand vous faites un projet comme
celui-là que vous ayez des gens qui part
postulat au fond disent ben on va
laisser faire les choses si on laisse
faire les choses il y aura plus
d'agriculture parce que je le répète
sans eau c'est on peut le dire comme on
veut dans un sens ou dans un autre sans
eau il n'y a pas d'agriculture possible
vous avez peut-être vu ce matin dans le
Parisien une enquête intéressante
sondage aimable qui raconte que 70% des
Français sont prêts aujourd'hui à
réduire leur consommation de viande
est-ce que vous applaudissez ça vous
dites voilà une évolution intéressante
pour s'adapter aux évolutions
climatiques que vous évoquez à un
instant et aux dérèglement là aussi
c'est paradoxe et les difficultés du
poste que j'occupe alors d'abord la
tendance globale c'est 2 à 3 % de
diminution de la production de la
consommation de viande et ça vient
corroborer ce que disent ce que dit ce
sondage c'est une question d'équilibre
de la ration alimentaire et c'est plutôt
un sujet de pays riche qu'un sujet riche
entre guillemets parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui nous écoutent qui
ont pas forcément les moyens de manger
de la viande tous les jours mais enfin
disons de pays qui ont plus des moyens
que d'autres dans beaucoup de pays on
est beaucoup sur des des fractions
alimentaires qui sont plutôt végétales
premier élément donc il y a une tendance
qui est lourde deuxième élément moi je
ne vois pas chez les éleveurs le fait
qu'il y ait une difficulté avec ça la
difficulté principale c'est la question
de la rémunération
troisième élément de la rémunération
c'est la question de la quantité
d'éleveur est-ce qu'il faut moins
d'éleveur aujourd'hui en France parce
que c'était mon troisième point non mais
c'est pas c'est pas grave on a si on est
dans la décarbonation on a deux sujets
c'est là qu'on est dans le les
difficultés c'est qu'on a des sujets en
particulier sur la le glissement des
engrais minéraux qui sont produits à
partir de pétrole et on voit bien les
conséquences que ça dans la crise
contraire vers les engrais organiques
les engrais organiques c'est quoi les
engrais organiques c'est l'élevage
donc on a à la fois besoin de mieux
équilibrer la ration alimentaire mais on
a besoin de garder l'élevage c'est sans
doute tout le monde dit que la grosse
qu'on appelle l'agroécologie la
nécessité d'avoir une agriculture qui
travaille avec l'écologie c'est une
agriculture qui va avoir besoin de
l'élevage et donc on a besoin on a un
modèle d'élevage parieur qui est plutôt
extensif qui développe plutôt un élevage
sur prairie 10% du stockage du carbone
aujourd'hui il se fait dans les prairies
si l'élevage disparaît qui qui va
stocker le carbone vous voyez ce que je
veux dire donc on a besoin là aussi à la
fois de gérer la question donc c'est un
faux en gros pour vous c'est un faux
sujet de demander aux gens de manger
moins de viande non non c'est pas non
j'ai pas dit ça la question de la durée
équilibrage est une question qui est
devant nous et c'est on sait que la
tendance existe et que c'est cette terre
est instable
serait équilibrage est plutôt nécessaire
dans la question du carbone mais j'ai
des éleveurs dont j'ai besoin dont nous
avons besoin la société a besoin des
éleveurs à la fois pour assurer notre
alimentation j'ajoute que sur un certain
nombre de produits je pense à la
volaille en particulier nous sommes
import Hornet donc on a besoin d'abord
sans doute de reconquérir notre
souveraineté dans ce domaine mais par
ailleurs il y a besoin c'est pour ça que
je parle de la rémunération si vous
dites simplement aux gens dans un dans
les dans un modèle ou il y aura moins de
de bovins il y aura moins d'ovins ou
autre et qui a pas la rémunération en
face vous voyez bien l'impasse dans
laquelle on place les jambes donc on a
une difficulté c'est sans doute moins de
viande mais sans doute mieux rémunéré de
contenu des services qu'elle rend par
ailleurs mais malgré tous nos
écosystèmes vous avez pas abordé le
troisième point parce que moi j'ai pas
compris il en faut toujours autant des
éleveurs il faut envisager sur un
certain calendrier de réduire la
quantité qu'on a il va se passer dans
les années qui viennent je distingue le
cheptel pardon animal du nombre
d'éleveurs on a besoin d'autant
d'éleveurs si ce n'est de plus
d'éleveurs parce qu'il y a un certain
nombre de territoires qui étaient en
polycan système de polyculture élevage
donc il faut déjà peut-être plus petit
probablement plus moins plus extensif
qui permettent d'avoir à la fois des
activités de culture et des activités
d'élevage et ça sur lequel il faut
travailler avec les éleveurs mais pas
avec le sentiment simplement regardez ce
qui s'est passé au Pays-Bas Pays-Bas ils
ont dit on va réduire le nombre
d'éleveurs et on va on réduit le cheptel
et derrière on réduit le nom d'éleveur
résultat ils sont dans une situation de
blocage
il n'avancent pas sur le sujet alors ils
avaient beaucoup de retard par rapport à
nous ils avaient un modèle sans doute
qui était moins extensif que le nôtre et
par ailleurs je le dis donc on a on a
besoin d'autant d'éleveurs si ce n'est
plus parce que pour produire du lait
faut des éleveurs les pieds parce qu'on
peut pas à la fois dire il faut moins
d'éleveurs et dire on veut un système
extensif parce que si jamais vous en
avez moins pour une production même si
elle diminue un peu équivalente ça veut
dire que vous aurez à l'éleveur plus de
plus de bovins pour revenir dans cette
dans cette catégorie là et donc on a
besoin avec les éleveurs de construire
une trajectoire qui soit une trajectoire
qui permette de se tenir à ce à cette
affaire carbone mais par ailleurs de
maintenir l'élevage puisque le maintenir
de le réhabiliter dans les fonctions qui
sont les siennes y compris en termes
d'agroécologie c'est un élément
absolument central pour moi il y a deux
sujets sur le carbone c'est l'élevage et
les fertilisants en minéraux c'est sur
ces deux sujets qu'il faut travailler
mais l'INRA travaille actuellement avec
d'autres d'ailleurs avec des instituts
de l'élevage sur une modification des
rations alimentaires des des bovins
c'est plutôt le bovin qui est un sujet
sur le sur le les gaz à effet de serre
une évolution des rations alimentaires
qui permettrait de réduire de 20 à 30%
les dégagements de gaz à effet de serre
donc ça aussi c'est une piste donc
rentrée simplement sur un modèle qui
soit un modèle de la décroissance moi je
pense que c'est une erreur quand on a de
toute façon besoin
d'alimenter nos populations et que nous
sommes importateurs nets sur un certain
nombre de produits justement par
ailleurs pardon de vous dire on est 7
milliards d'habitants sur la terre on
sera 10 milliards et dans un modèle de
dérèglement climatique qui va faire
qu'on aura beaucoup plus d'un coup et de
période où on va manquer qui de céréales
et donc de quoi nourrir les animaux
prendre le risque d'être simplement dans
un modèle décroissant c'est un prendre
un risque qui ne vous considérer que
notre assiette à nous les français elle
est elle est bonne pour l'environnement
ça dépend comment par quel bout vous le
prenez si vous prenez l'assiette sous
l'angle de la biodiversité le maintien
des paysages de maintien des prairies la
lutte contre le défense contre
l'incendie le modèle que nous avons
d'élevage est un bon modèle si vous le
prenez simplement sur le critère carbone
c'est là que c'est complexe notre
affaire si vous le prenez simplement sur
le critère carbone tout le monde sait
que l'élevage a une part importante et
que donc qui a par la recherche et
l'innovation des choses à faire et
peut-être par les évolutions par les
évolutions d'alimentation mais c'est su
depuis longtemps qu'il faut rééquilibrer
un c'est pas une nouveauté du jour j'ai
vu aussi en prépa l'émission que la
moitié de nos fruits de nos légumes
qu'on consomme était importés vous êtes
ministre également de la souveraineté
alimentaire est-ce que c'est un problème
oui c'est un problème c'est un problème
qui a plusieurs facteurs on peut pas à
la fois dire il faut aller vers plus de
fruits et légumes et qu'on soit
importateur net sans doute on a un sujet
de compétitivité c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de compenser au travers d'un dispositif
qui vise à alléger les charges sociales
pour les employeurs saisonniers parce
que ça c'est un élément important sans
doute aussi parce qu'on a interdit chez
nous des molécules qui n'étaient pas
interdites à à l'intérieur de l'espace
européen vous parlez pas avec l'Espagne
par exemple il y a des produits qui ont
été interdits sur la sur la cerise il y
a une dizaine d'années en France où sept
huit en France qui ont été interdits que
très récemment au niveau européen la
résultat des courses quand vous n'avez
pas l'alternative
vous avez des on a perdu la moitié au
moins la moitié de notre verger de
cerise donc on a les tomates donc on a
rien gagné si on a quand même gagné
quelque chose on a si on a gagné qu'on
produit moins qu'on produit moins de
fruits et légumes donc on utilise moins
d'eau donc on a oui mais enfin alors on
peut aussi sauf qu'on prend l'autre chez
les voisins mais oui mais c'est un peu
je voulais vous poser c'est que on veut
pas importer le soja du Brésil parce
qu'il prend du carbone et on veut bien
apporter de la cerise d'ailleurs parce
qu'elle prend de l'eau ah non chacun
doit faire sa part parce qu'à un moment
que vous posez c'est en termes
d'arbitrage qu'est-ce que vous préférez
on a besoin mais on a besoin d'être auto
suffisant au moins autosuffisant en
fruits et légumes et pour cela on a
besoin d'eau on va pas celui qui dirait
aujourd'hui sous vos yeux que il faut
qu'on construise un modèle sans eau
c'est celui qui renonce à l'agriculture
et celui qui renonce à l'alimentation et
vous êtes après dans les de tous ceux
qui feront de l'alimentation une arme
mais vous détestez vous vous constatez
parfaitement l'état des lieux mais vous
nous donnez pas vos arbitrages c'est à
dire qu'on est en train de choisir quoi
qu'est-ce qui va se passer là dans les
années qui viennent on veut être
autosuffisant en fruits en légumes oui
donc vous allez interdire qu'on consomme
des tas de fruits exotiques
c'est simplement par la reconquête ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'on aide nos
producteurs avec des investissements il
faut qu'ils puissent avoir accès à l'eau
par exemple en arboriculture ou en
France et légumes on développe un modèle
sur le maraîchage on dit qu'il faut plus
de maraîchers des maraîchers sans eau
c'est pas la peine d'en parler c'est de
la littérature donc si on veut
reconquérir de son permaculture je crois
qu'il y a des expériences intéressantes
si vous me trouvez un modèle dans lequel
on peut planter et on peut faire pousser
sans eau puis il y a quand même besoin
d'eau bon donc je vous dis tout à
l'heure qu'on essaie de regarder sur des
volumes et c'est ce qui c'est ce que
font les agriculteurs dans un certain
nombre de démarches exemplaires donc on
a besoin d'eau donc si on veut
reconquérir notre souveraineté
alimentaire par exemple sur la question
des fruits et légumes et que vous me
dites oui moi ça nous a évité de
consommer de l'eau oui enfin l'eau est
consommée ailleurs et donc on a quand
même solidarité collective alors à ce
moment-là on n'est pas gêné qu'on fasse
venir du soja des de du Brésil quel
produit de la déforestation il faut
qu'on essaie d'être de l'eau importée
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle il y a le
carbone apporté mais ça ça s'appelle de
l'eau importée mais ça c'est pas alors
que vous me disiez souvent que ça vient
d'ailleurs d'Italie et de l'Espagne et
que dans ces pays-là ils ont un stress
hydrique qui est plus puissant que
l'autre donc on a une responsabilité à
faire qu'est-ce qu'on a à faire sur la
question du carbone c'est à la fois des
pratiques qui permettent de mieux quel
carbone
et il y a du potentiel dans les prairies
il y a du potentiel dans les grandes
cultures aujourd'hui
2,3% du stockage pack carbone il se fait
sur sur les prairies ou sur les grandes
cultures parce que si on arrivait 2,3
pour 1000 pardon si on arrive à 4 pour
1000 on compenserait quasiment
l'augmentation des gaz à effet donc ça
c'est les pratiques agricoles et puis
deuxièmement dans notre assiette et par
notre consommation
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans la loi egalim
et gallima et Gallim 2 on peut orienter
pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait un mix
produit carnet produit fruits et légumes
qui soit nature et autres serrés et
autres qui soient de nature différente
donc il faut travailler sur l'ensemble
des pistes vous voyez ce que je veux
dire dans le modèle qu'on essaie de
construire de l'agroécologie il y a
derrière parce que c'est pas ce que vous
dites mais des gens qui disent on serait
mieux sans élevage mais on a besoin de
l'élevage parce que la fertilisation
c'est pas une nouveauté du moment ça
fait 2000 ans ça fait 10000 ans je
voudrais juste savoir pour que ce soit
très clair pour les auditeurs et
téléspectateurs et ce qu'il faut
s'attendre en plus du coup de l'énergie
qui est en train d'augmenter et dont on
peut imaginer que ça va durer un certain
temps on voit que ça va pas s'arranger
vraiment est-ce qu'on peut considérer
que se nourrir correctement sera de plus
en plus cher si on veut avoir des fruits
et légumes français si on veut avoir le
problème se pose très concrètement en ce
moment avec les cantines scolaires on
explique souvent donnera un peu moins
enfin on dit qu'on ne le fera pas mais
on peut se demander et soit on mangera
pas des bons produits parce que c'est
trop cher là vous allez me répondre sur
l'électricité ou sur l'énergie de temps
est-ce que globalement le message c'est
et bien oui on va manger plus cher ou si
on veut bien manger ça sera plus cher ou
alors on va manger moins
est-ce qu'il le faut est-ce que la vertu
se pèse et il faut graduer aussi en
fonction de d'ailleurs de ceux qui nous
écoutent et qui ont pas le même les
mêmes moyens aujourd'hui 12 à 14% de la
de la dépense des ménages elle est
consacrée à l'alimentation
l'essentiel d'ailleurs du stress c'est
le logement le déplacement et d'autres
d'autres consommations qui sont un peu
vous considérez comme quelques
économistes qu'on dépense pas assez
d'argent pour pour l'alimentation
en sortie de guerre d'avoir le plus
d'alimentation possible la plus variée
possible la moins chère possible mais il
faut qu'on inverse un peu cette
philosophie parce que si on veut avoir
des produits qui puissent intégrer dans
leur coup
c'est quand même la seule matière sur
laquelle on passe son temps à faire des
promotions et à dire je vous achète une
boîte de carottes pour une boîte de
carottes achetées vous en avez deux
jamais on vous dit pour tel téléphone
vous en avez deux donc il faut permettre
aux agriculteurs de vendre leurs
produits il faut permettre aux
agriculteurs alors sachant que je prends
le cas du lait pour vous donner un
exemple très concret 50 euros des
millilitres de plus ça permet aux
éleveurs laitiers de vivre 50 euros ça
fait 0,05 euros un simple coup
je dis pas que tout le monde peut
l'assumer mais 005 euros du Lite c'est
pas insurmontable quel est le problème
aujourd'hui alors qu'on a en partie
résolu où est le problème exactement
dans la chaîne mais il y a plusieurs
problèmes c'est un qu'on a dévalorisé
collectivement le prix et la valeur de
l'alimentation alors que c'est un
élément essentiel et que dedans le cadre
du dérèglement climatique les les
contraintes qui pèsent
changement climatique décarbonation vont
faire que il y a forcément un
renchérisse à renchérissement on le voit
bien d'ailleurs sur le bio le coup du
bio est plus élevé pourquoi parce qu'on
a un rendement qui est moins grand on a
un accès à la main d'oeuvre qui est plus
important on a besoin de plus de main
d'oeuvre problème de votre équation à
deux inconnues c'est que le revenu de
l'agriculteur lui n'augmente pas alors
attends
les lois qu'on a été produites par mes
prédécesseurs la deuxième en particulier
portée par Julien de Normandie et Gallim
2 elle vise à faire quoi à construire le
prix à partir des coûts de production du
producteur alors qu'avant c'était le
distributeur qui disait son bruit
d'objectif
et qui faisait que il faisait la
pression en bout de chaîne c'était
l'agriculteur le producteur qui était
pénalisé et là
alors attendez jusqu'à la guerre
jusqu'au 24 février on a constaté
l'inflation ça peut marcher voilà hors
inflation ça a marché et d'ailleurs
quand vous croisez tout le monde il y a
un rapport qui est sorti aujourd'hui
encore qui avait été commandé par Bruno
Le Maire qui montre bien que les
agriculteurs jusqu'au moment de la
guerre en Ukraine ils ont pu intégrer
pour la première fois depuis 10 ans une
hausse puisque on a une hausse moyenne
alors ces variables selon les
productions de 3,5%. alors que pendant
10 ans
les prix agricoles avaient diminué ce
rapport dit également que les
agriculteurs ne sont pas des profiteurs
de
ce qui avait pu dire monsieur Leclerc
qui avait dit qu'il y avait des
profiteurs de guerre et c'est pour ça
que le rapport a été fait hein
qui avait dit il a un nom et un prénom
vous avez raison mais
vous avez raison qui avait dit qu'il y
avait des profiteurs de guerre la vérité
qui a pas des profiteurs de guerre
quelle est la difficulté
la grande distribution n'a pas envie de
payer plus cher les produits agrumés
toutes les semaines un comité des
relations commerciales pour dire que on
doit se tenir à la loi egali mais quand
il y a des sanctions il doit y en avoir
et deux qu'il faut que les comportements
changent il a été annoncé par mes
collègues liste Roland Lescure Olivia
Grégoire des sanctions que nous avions
demandé après un audit sur les pénalités
logistiques c'est à dire que
c'est vrai que les la construction de
prix se fait mieux mais en forme en
forme de dérèglement inflationniste
évidemment le passage des prix est plus
laborieux et beaucoup plus difficile et
c'est ça sur lequel on travaille pour
faire en sorte que en continu puisse
faire évoluer les prix mais la question
de la rémunération des agriculteurs
qu'on a commencé à traiter devant dans
egalim c'est une question qui est
largement j'étais assez étonné je vous
dis juste une seconde j'étais en réunion
des ministres de l'Agriculture à l'OCDE
c'est ces jours-ci à Paris le nombre de
ministres qui nous ont demandé ce qui
était égalime 2 et en quoi c'était
intéressant pour eux parce qu'il voit à
quel point la faible rémunération de
l'agriculture c'est à la fin la
disparition des agriculteurs et à la fin
la perte de souveraineté et j'étais très
favorablement impressionné par le fait
que beaucoup de pays compris de de
philosophie plus libérales nous disent
on est intéressé par ce que vous faites
par égaline parce que ça permet de dire
que la pression peut pas être sur les
producteurs
France Inter
[Musique]
hashtag question Paul Marc phénom
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire je le précise
avec nous jusqu'à 13h en direct sur
France Inter et France Info la
télévision peut-être avec vous lu Le
Journal du Dimanche ce matin on évoque
une dissolution dans quelques mois la
question selon les journalistes n'est
plus de savoir si il y aura une des
solutions mais quand il y aura une
dissolution est-ce que vous l'accueillez
vous l'attendez avec appétit puisqu'on
parle beaucoup d'alimentation ce midi
écoutez demain les épisodes électoraux
pour en avoir vécu quelques-uns donc
c'est pas le sujet mais voyez bien
qu'avec les sujets qu'on évoque mon
sujet principal n'est pas de savoir s'il
y a une dissolution et quand il y aura
une dissolution c'est d'essayer de
résoudre les problèmes qu'on a de vendre
mais les problèmes étant des problèmes
politiques on ne peut pas balayer comme
ça la question politique
cette majorité relative il y a
évidemment la question de est-ce qu'il y
a une dissolution moi je considère que
les termes sont pas posés c'est ce que
dit d'ailleurs l'article aujourd'hui
pour une solution qu'est-ce que serait
les nécessités d'une dissolution ça
serait un blocage institutionnel
suffisamment puissant ou que nous soyons
dans une situation d'impossibilité
et c'est peut-être pas le cas sur
d'autres
énergies renouvelables est-ce qu'il y a
pas moyen de trouver un point
d'équilibre entre l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat j'ai été mis votre votre
suppléante qui a votre place de député
du Loir-et-Cher se dit médusé par l'état
de l'Assemblée nationale ça n'a rien à
voir enfin c'est pas l'impression
qu'elle dit que ça fonctionne ça c'est
on a un sujet objectivement démocratique
devant nous je trouve que le spectacle
qui est donné à l'Assemblée nationale
content de gens y compris ceux qui nous
écoutent aujourd'hui sont dans la
difficulté se demande pour les
agriculteurs s'ils vont pouvoir passer
l'année pour un certain nombre de gens
qui vont pouvoir boucler leurs fins de
moi assister à ce à quoi on assiste à
l'Assemblée nationale qui donne
franchement pas le sentiment de
s'occuper du principal mais plutôt de
s'occuper de posture je comprends qu'on
puisse être médusé ou étonné ça ce qu'on
a l'impression aussi que vous êtes
beaucoup concentré enfin vous la
majorité contre la nups et que vous avez
un peu oublié le rassemblement national
qui s'est rappelé à notre souvenir bon
pas franchement cette semaine avec
l'histoire de qu'il parte en Afrique il
rentre en Afrique
qui est responsable pour vous de cette
espèce de côté est-ce que c'est le fait
simplement qu'une majorité relative ou
parce qu'il y a des comportements
politiques qui ont mal à évolué moi je
m'abstrais jamais les cours
responsabilités quand vous êtes en
situation de responsabilité politique
vous dites jamais c'est tous les autres
et pas nous mais quand même globalement
ce que vous voyez à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un certain nombre de
part et d'autre des extrêmes de
l'hémicycle les gens qui n'ont qu'une en
tête c'est de profiter de la crise au
sens électoral du terme de crise ce sont
des profiteurs électoraux de crise c'est
à dire que une vive que sur la crise moi
ce que je souhaiterais eux comme les
autres il y a des plus modérés dans ces
franges là chez les LR au parti
socialistes et sans doute à Europe
écologique ou chez même les communistes
on pourrait peut-être dans cette période
de crise il y a eu des périodes
historiques vous excluez le RN là vous
avez fait
parce que
j'ai dit Parti communiste pour jeudi
essayons de voir ceux qui se comportent
comme s'il devait un jour gouverner pas
simplement comme s'il devait
mettre à bas les gouvernants parce que
cette posture qui est la posture
permanente de la critique sans avoir des
solutions qui sont sur la table dont on
puisse penser qu'elle soit tenable c'est
une posture assez facile et donc ça ça
la démocratie s'ouvre de gens qui ne se
mettent pas en situation de et si moi
j'étais en situation de gouverner
qu'est-ce que est-ce que je dirais
quelque chose de différent que dans la
situation d'opposition moi il m'est
arrivé dans l'opposition plutôt au
niveau local je me suis jamais mis dans
la situation de dire quelque chose que
j'aurais regretté de dire si j'étais en
situation de gouverner un jour et donc
là on a pardon juste une seconde on a on
a des comportements qui sont des
comportements qui sont de l'ordre de
nourrir le chaos ou sans féliciter et de
ne jamais essayer de trouver des
solutions est-ce que le gouvernement un
comportement irréprochable à l'intérieur
de la même façon la majorité
présidentielle est suffisamment
conciliante pour discuter avec ce que
vous appelez les parties de gouvernement
il me semble que la première ministre y
compris dans son discours de politique
générale y compris le président de la
République à l'issue du
des épisodes électoraux du printemps
dernier de l'été dernier
loi de finance rectificative au mois de
juillet il y a un certain nombre de
choses qui avaient été demandé par les
uns ou par les autres qui ont permis qui
ont permis que certains puissent
s'abstenir donc et quand on
reconnaissons
Gard de comment de débats sur le budget
notamment sur la partie dépenses ça
représente quasiment rien 400 millions
alors c'est beaucoup effectivement à
l'échelle pour un Français mais 400
millions c'est zéro virgule 5 % du
budget global c'est rien donc est-ce
qu'il y a vraiment la volonté d'écouter
d'essayer de travailler avec
l'opposition et d'arriver à des
compromis on n'a pas je vous assure
c'est ce qu'a fait Gabriel Attal
d'ailleurs dans ces dialogues de Bercy a
essayé de trouver des chemins mais après
on a quand même une situation de
responsabilité qui fait qu'on peut pas
rajouter 3 4 5 10 milliards sans se
poser la question quand même de à quel
taux on va emprunter pardon c'est c'est
assez commode de faire de la dépense
sans se poser la question de la recette
et donc il y a aussi un cap qu'on entend
tenir et que d'autres pourraient tenir
avec nous d'ailleurs qui est un cap de
la
l'exigence budgétaire mais sur les super
profits par exemple qui pourraient
permettre de financer certaines choses
vous gardez aussi un cap vous n'avez pas
envie de
comme le modèle j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
débat qui avait été posé
mon ami Jean-Paul Mattei qui est en
train de se poser
je trouve pas complètement
indécente se poser la question dans
cette période de crise de comment sont
répartis les profits je trouve pas ça
complètement vous avez entendu le
ministre de l'économie à quelques
semaines dire qu'il ne savait pas ce qui
était un super profit oui alors ça c'est
peut-être des débats de sémantique mais
c'est pas la question de choquer après
on peut avoir des débats entre nous
enfin il est pas complètement illégitime
qu'on ait des débat entre nous il y a
des il y a des mais d'ailleurs le super
profit n'est pas le pour moi lié il y a
pas à vilipender une entreprise vous
avez des des c'est pas c'est pas des
profiteurs c'est ce qu'on distingue mal
d'ailleurs dans cette affaire mais à la
vérité c'est ce qu'on fait aussi au
niveau européen puisque il y a un
certain nombre de profits qui sont
qualifiés comme ça d'ailleurs au niveau
européen qui vont permettre d'alimenter
le fond qui va permettre de soutenir les
entreprises qui ont des dépenses
d'énergie qui sont trop fortes donc peu
importe la terminologie
vous auriez pu tendre la main à
l'opposition quasiment toutes les
oppositions le demandent à l'exception
des LR oui mais allô allô de la logique
il faut quand on la main il faut être
chacun loyal le bout de la logique c'est
si vous tendez la main c'est qu'au bout
vous abstenez je demande même pas de
voter pour votez pas compte le budget
alors toutes ces oppositions annoncées
par postulat de démarrage alors sauf si
on faisait un budget personne n'avait
cru à la taxation des super profits non
mais c'est pas l'élément déterminant
vous voyez bien que sur les dépenses
aurait-elle non mais il y a toujours
quelque chose on va voir d'ailleurs sur
la question des énergies renouvelables
alors si on trouve pas à l'Assemblée
nationale quelque chose qui soit un
équilibre on verra ce que disent les
écoles juste parce qu'il préfère le
statu quo mais des avancées même si
elles ne vont pas assez loin le problème
dans cette affaire là c'est que le
compromis qui venait pas pour moi une
compromission c'est un moment de faire
un pas vers les autres si vous dites on
fait un pas et que toute façon vous
votez contre alors à ce moment-là la
main tendue ne sert à rien ça vient un
peu à l'encontre de ce que vous disiez
au début en disant l'assemblée elle vit
quand même etc là on sent qu'il y a des
blocages puisque vous dites en face de
vous il y a des gens qui auront selon
vos mots des postulats de départ qui
font qu'il n'y a pas compris possible
donc la dissolution c'est c'est
l'évidence je ne dis pas je ne renonce
pas à l'idée je trouvais sur des sujets
comme ceux qu'on vient d'évoquer alors
des terrains je ne je suis quelqu'un qui
défend le Parlement et donc je trouve
qu'à chaque fois que le Parlement
n'arrive pas à trouver des terrains de
compromis c'est un échec regardez à la
santé au Sénat ils ont trouvé des voies
de compromis ils sont pas tous mono
colorés au Sénat et ils ont quasiment
tous voté la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables absolument deux choses
très jolies très très concrètes l'idée
d'un dividende salarié qui est porté par
un certain nombre de ministres pas
d'Olivia Grégoire ou vous avez l'air
d'être favorable vous pensez que c'est
un espoir c'est une piste après faut
regarder il faut creuser les choses il
me semble l'idée que quand on donne des
dividendes au-delà d'un certain seuil
aux actionnaires ont pu s'en donner aux
salariés oui mais c'est la question de
la répartition
mais je suis d'accord avec l'idée qu'on
puisse réfléchir à la mi-arrière
répartition des dividendes salariés et
les et les actions finissent sur vos
alliances matin Bruno Le Maire dit dans
une interview LR a voté la loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur l'assurance chômage
sur les énergies renouvelables comme
disait claire il me paraît légitime de
réfléchir un accord plus consolidé entre
les républicains et notre majorité
est-ce que c'est vers les LR comme
l'avait laissé entendre Emmanuel Macron
sur France 2 tout en disant que c'était
sur des sujets spécifiques ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut effectivement faire
non pas un pacte comme disait Sarkozy
mais quelque chose de plus abouti que
des alliances au parcours alors c'est
peut-être le centriste qui va s'exprimer
je pense que je ne désespère pas du fait
qu'on puisse discuter avec des LR mais
qu'on puisse trouver à gauche en même
temps c'est le projet que nous avons
construit en 2017
prospère assez assez facilement et assez
connotément à la fois et ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur la misère des
gens qu'on puisse trouver de part et moi
la question n'est pas de savoir si c'est
des majorités alternatives avec la
droite sur le nucléaire avec la gauche
ou les écolos sur le renouvelables on
pense que ça peut se faire je vous
demande si ça doit être formulé
formalisé
je vous dis que c'est à chaque contenu
est-ce qu'on un intérêt à développer les
énergies renouvelables à la réponse est
oui alors essayons de trouver un
compromis est-ce qu'on a intérêt à
avancé sur la question des retraites la
réponse est oui essayons d'avoine et
donc excusez-moi
politique que tout le monde n'est pas le
même matériel souvent votre intérêt
comme étant l'intérêt général non j'ai
pas dit ça mais il me semble que la fin
on peut au moins partager autour de
cette table après on peut rentrer dans
le détail si vous l'avez fait tout à
l'heure madame Gatineau sur les
questions de téléchargement en énergie
Nova mais est-ce qu'on est pour le
est-ce qu'on veut rester dans le statu
quo des énergies renouvelables il me
semble que collectivement on est plutôt
d'accord avec l'idée qu'il faut avancer
sur ce sujet certains diront qu'il faut
aller plus loin d'autres diront mais
tout avancé ce qui est désespérant dans
ce pays dans les questions que je traite
comme dans les autres c'est qu'à force
de rester dans les postures on avance
pas j'aimerais un peu de pragmatisme
alors nous n'avons pas la culture du
compromis et de la coalition dans ce
pays je discutais avec mon collègue
également pas plus tard il y a deux
jours ils ont une culture puissante pour
continuer comme ça on l'aura jamais oui
est-ce que vous m'entendez dire autre
quelque chose que nécessité qu'on essaie
d'avancer que c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas les clés
et qu'un certain nombre de gens qui s'y
opposent pour des raisons parfois
conjoncturelles
et d'autres pour des raisons plus
structurelles est-ce qu'il faut pour
autant renoncer à attendre la main et
essayer avec les uns ou avec les autres
sur des sujets qui nous paraissent des
sujets d'intérêt général les sujets
énergétiques sont des sujets d'intérêt
général les sujets budgétaires sont des
sujets d'intérêt général si on peut on
peut pas avancer avec un certain nombre
d'entre eux on renonce même à la
capacité à agir donc vous ce que vous
voulez vous c'est des compromis avec la
gauche avec la droite et si on résume en
gros vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec cette
alliance qui a demandé Emmanuel Macron
le 26 octobre dernier vous essayez de me
faire dire que je suis pas d'accord avec
une alliance mais de comprendre non non
mais j'essaie de vous expliquer comment
je vois les choses je dis que
structurellement on a besoin de pouvoir
discuter avec un certain nombre de gens
qui sur les sujets que nous pourrions
partager pourraient trouver un compromis
avec nous le compromis c'est chacun fait
un pas premier élément deuxième élément
reconnaissant aujourd'hui que sur un
certain nombre de textes c'est plutôt
les
on l'a vu d'ailleurs au Sénat sur les
questions de nouveau d'énergie
renouvelables qui ont essayé de faire
les pas du compromis mais ça pas parce
que eux le font et que c'est plus
visible et qu'il faut plutôt
l'encourager on doit par ailleurs ne pas
décourager sur les autres sujets il y a
un parti dans on a presque pas parlé
c'est un vieux parti maintenant 50 ans
le rassemblement national qui a un jeune
président depuis hier Jordan Bardella
est-ce que pour vous c'est un parti
comme un autre
on va vous dire soit c'est un parti dont
on juge qu'il est anti-démocratique et
et que donc il ne peut pas être dans le
champ politique
premièrement de la réponse c'est un de
ce point de vue là c'est un parti commun
comme un autre après dans sa philosophie
pour moi ça n'est pas un parti comme un
autre parce qu'il porte on l'a encore vu
cette semaine dans son expression dans
ses valeurs
des risques qui nous ont toujours fait
nous pour ce qui est du Mouvement
Démocrate historiquement un peu plus
avant refuser toute forme de compromis
de compromission de donc
il est dans le champ démocratique élu ou
alors on dit que il doit être interdit
du champ démocratique mais il n'est pas
un parti comme un autre parce que les
comment dirais-je la philosophie qu'il
porte est une philosophie philosophie
mortifère
Marine Le Pen assumer choisi comme un
élément marketing et quelque chose
auquel vous croyez en clair il y a eu un
accident de parcours cette semaine à
l'Assemblée avec les propos tenus par
Grégoire de Fournas ou est-ce que
finalement c'est comme on dit les autres
tout seul naturel qui revient
au galop alors parce que c'est plutôt
chasser le naturel on voit bien que les
tentations qui sont celles alors là
c'est une partie et quand on écoute le
discours de Jordan barbella vous y
trouvez une
quelque chose qui ressemble à ce que
disait Marine Le Pen avant ou vous
trouvez qu'il y a une ça durcie moi j'ai
plutôt le sentiment que ça durcit mais
j'ai l'impression quand même que le
ministre de l'Intérieur du gouvernement
donc Gérald Darmanin ne reprend pas un
peu trop la rhétorique du rassemblement
national et et qui du coup la valide
cette semaine il a présenté donc les
contours avec Olivier du soft de son de
programme du projet d'immigration du
plan qui sera à discuter à la rentrée
prochain en novembre en janvier à peu
près à l'Assemblée nationale on évoque
notamment des questions des quotas
migratoires je crois qu'au modem c'est
pas votre truc non mais c'est pas parce
qu'il y a des sujets dont c'est saisi le
rassemblement national qu'on n'a pas le
droit de se préoccuper de ces sujets là
la question des quotas
la rhétorique je disais mais je ne
retrouve pas du tout la même rhétorique
Gérald Darmanin parce que sur la
question de l'accueil il dit il faut moi
accueillir mais mieux accueillir c'est
pas une rhétorique qui est très nouvelle
d'ailleurs je
j'écoutais les propos de François
Mitterrand il y a très longtemps sur le
sujet c'était c'est quand même la
question c'est d'arriver à le faire
sinon on reste dans la rhétorique quand
il dit une petite partie des étrangers
est responsable d'une grande partie des
faits de délinquance vous êtes d'accord
ou pas parce que là il fait clairement
un lien entre immigration et délinquance
ou pas je le pose pas comme ça la
question
j'ai bien entendu ce que vous me disiez
ce qu'il avait dit la question c'est les
fesses statistiques mais la question
c'est aussi quels sont les fondements de
ce constat là le fondement de ce constat
là c'est que il y a un certain nombre de
gens qui sont c'est parmi ces
populations là qu'on a le nombre de gens
qui sont le moins intégrés les plus
fragiles les plus les moins ayant accès
à l'emploi donc notre exigence pour
sortir du constat et pour qu'on arrive à
quelque chose de plus positif c'est de
renforcer l'intégration de faire en
sorte que notamment par le travail
ceux qui viennent sur notre territoire
pour des raisons moi je connais personne
qui partent de son pays personne par
plaisir personne ne prend sa valise et
quitte sa maison ses amis sa famille par
plaisir et pour des allocations ça c'est
la rhétorique ça c'est ce que dit Madame
Le Pen et c'est ce que disent Madame Le
Pen et ses amis mais qu'après une fois
sur le sol français d'abord on dise
c'est pas nous qui l'avons dit c'est un
ancien Premier ministre appelé Michel
Rocard
on ne peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde mais virgule mais chacun
c'est pour ça qu'il faut tout prendre
dans la phrase et vous avez raison mais
chacun doit prendre sa part prendre sa
part c'est s'assurer quand on accueille
des gens qu'on les met dans des
situations qui soient des situations
d'intégration
c'est s'assurer aussi que lorsque le
métier n'est plus en tension de leur
dire de repartir chez eux bah c'est ce
qui arrive dans la plupart des pays du
monde vous avez personne ne critique la
politique migratoire canadienne personne
personne ne pense que le Canada n'est
pas un pays démocratique on apprend peu
on vérifie
les tests
suffisamment puissant pour penser que
les métiers en tension ça n'est pas
quelque chose qui va beaucoup et du
moyen terme du Olivier du stop Gérald
Darmanin j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une
espèce de brouillage entre les auqtf il
y en aura plus et ça sera systématique
et on va faire venir des gens est-ce que
finalement pour contrer le rassemblement
national faudrait pas avoir un message
plus clair mais c'est la grande
difficulté que nous avons face aux
populistes c'est d'essayer d'avoir des
paroles qui soit équilibrées pas
caricatural c'est à dire de ne pas être
entre les propos de ce qu'ils disent
portes ouvertes
mais il me semble que le le à la fois le
projet de loi et l'expression quand
Olivier du soft et Gérald Darmanin c'est
équilibre qu'on cherche dans la petite
question c'est pas trop difficile d'être
ministre sous Emmanuel Macron qui semble
maîtriser tous les dossiers ou en tout
cas qui intervient surtout les dossiers
c'est pas difficile parce que ça montre
son intérêt à tous les dossiers donc ça
ça pousse le niveau d'exigence donc je
trouve ça plutôt bien vous avez des
marches de manœuvre ça va oui j'ai
jamais eu un sentiment il y a longtemps
que j'ai eu des marges de manœuvre
François Bayrou vous le dirai
encore mieux que je ne le dis là et donc
je me sens jamais vous envoyer je me
sens je me suis je me sens mais après
c'est faut pas être prétentieux dans la
vie donc que vous ayez une expression
que vous ayez une position qu'elle soit
reprise partiellement par ou totalement
ça c'est la vie politique merci merci
nous la vie politique c'est la fin de
question politique